okay so definitely the mashup isn't
something that you play a party but a
Christian it's really hard to say that
they don't send a lot like each other
when you listen to that
yeah the mash-up sounds a little bit off
because they're in different keys but
essentially from that you can tell that
the timing the rhythm of the melody that
pays the tempo and the actual melodic
contour if you like the notes themselves
are pretty almost identical match
explained copyright in music for us
because this was about the melody but
when you're talking about the chords and
the general makeup of a song when it
would it different rules apply there are
certain aspects certain musical aspects
that are not protectable under copyright
laws so a chord sequence for example you
can't copyright an actual progression of
chords because our under start the
Western European understanding of
tonality of music is that certain chords
are expected to be rests in certain
directions so you know there's a there's
a certain type of analysis where you can
reduce every piece of music to three
chords one five one so you wouldn't
expect elements like rhythm tempo the
key harmony on their own to be
protectable but when there are
accumulative effects they can be
considered in a copyright infringement
case the most if you like the most
valuable part of a piece of music is its
melody is the bit that people remember
the bit that people sing it's generally
the melody will be the hook although
there are examples of pieces of music
where for example Queen with the you
know the two drums and the clap you mean
that would be a rhythm that's actually
considered a hook so we will rock you
you couldn't you you couldn't sue for
copyright if you use there it would be
it would be really it'd be a dangerous
thing for somebody to release a song
that has that predominantly through it
or starts off with that you know it
starts in the same way that might make
people think when they hear the
beginning of that song that it's its
Queen song and we've had a couple as
Dan's report said Marvin Gaye's estate
and Robin Thicke and Pharrell Williams
for the two songs that clash they're Led
Zeppelin recently had one
or come up with a band that the chord
sequence period spirit and their way to
heaven yeah this one is different though
because it's the melody yeah so other
high-profile cases that we've seen
recently have been more based on really
ambiguous things like feel and groove
and soul which are you know sort of
indistinguishable elements of a song but
when it comes down as a melody and
particular melody in a chorus you're
looking at a valuable piece of a piece
of music and there's no particular
danger that this happens more often in
the pop industry because it is so
commercialized and there is a real
formula to a successful pop song yeah at
the end of the day commercial music is
written to make money it's kind of
prescriptive in certain senses it needs
to be of a certain duration so that it
will be played on radio the way that
radio airplay is work with commercial
breaks etc so you're looking at a
two-minute piece of music within that it
has to fulfill as a tick certain boxes
so you expect there to be an
introduction of verse or chorus maybe an
instrumental section so when you start
boiling it down in terms of structure it
is quite familiar almost it's not don't
the kind of cheap in it but it's a
little bit like painting by numbers in
some respects when you're trying to get
certain take certain boxes and get
certain parts of structuring together so
then when you're talking about say for
example a ballad where you know the
features if the features aren't there
people won't consider it a ballad today
you started to reduce it boil it down
into a very formulaic way of writing and
therefore it's not surprising all that
people can you know often end up with
crossover between different music it's a
really interesting aspect of music and
one we could talk about for a long time
a Christian said hell thanks very much
for coming Italy that's about it